[Music]
all right every day I enjoy picking out
something cool from social media to
share in case you may have overlooked it
this is what I'm
liking some kids just know from early on
what they're going to be in life what
they want to be and for me singing was
there was no other option I was
definitely screwed if it wasn't singing
uh for a Michigan woman paleontology was
the right choice for her it's a decision
she made when she was 7 years old
visiting the dinosaur exhibit at the
Field museum in Chicago and Rec she
celebrated just how far she's come since
then sharing a photo of her first trip
to the museum alongside a photo of her
now doing research there which is so
incredible we have her on the line right
now watching on WXYZ TV everybody say
hello to
lanaa hi
hi oh my God first of all I love the
photos next to each other so what was
your first visit there
like um so the first photo I was on a
vacation to Chicago with my parents um
and we visited the field museum where
they had this exhibit that was basically
just this giant sandbox that was filled
with bones um so you could go dig up
your own dinosaur um and there was
someone there to explain what
paleontology even is and I think that
was the first time that I even learned
what a dinosaur was so I was like oh my
God that's so cool that's what I want to
be when I grow up um and then there was
this station where you could make a
model of the bone so my mom took this
like Extremely Goofy looking photo of me
um and that's how that happened I love
it so explain it like in the next
picture like you're going back and now
you're a researcher in this field that
you wanted to do when you were seven
that's so cool what was that full circle
moment like yeah so um I grew up and
then I decided that I was going to be a
paleontologist um so I did a M's at
University of Minnesota and my adviser
for my masters was actually the curator
from The Field Museum um and he was the
same guy who helped create that exhibit
that first got me interested in
paleontology so everything kind of came
full circle um and then we did a
research visit so we went back to the
collections and I was thinking this is
incredible um and I showed him that
goofy photo of me and he thought it was
hilarious so he went and grabbed the
exact same fossil and then he said here
you have to recreate this photo so then
I I did and I posted it and everyone
else thought it was equally
goofy no it's so cool and to dream
something you know that's a really cool
thing to dream as a kid and then to
actually for it to come to fruition is
incredible
congratulations thank you so much yeah
well thank you so much l I'm liking your
post right
now and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly Unstoppable people just like
you ma'am so they're going to be giving
you a check for $1,000 how's that
sound oh my God I love it thank you so
much L and thank you to all our guests
this hour Martha Stewart Pander Parker
CO Courtney and smoking nor you have a
great gain if it's
[Music]
[Applause]
not thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home